bonjour et bienvenue dans ce stade
science consacrée aujourd'hui à la
représentation la plus connue et la plus
controversée de l'histoire des sciences
la marche vers le progrès bien que
l'idée qu'elles représentent 7 de
l'homme descend du singe soit très
ancienne
l'image en elle même n'est apparu que
dans les années 60 dans le but de
fournir un support visuel afin de mieux
expliquer où en est l état des
connaissances sur l'origine et
l'évolution de l'homme et ce de façon
claire simple et accessible à tous et
depuis les nombreux détournements qu'il
soit humoristique politique ou
mercantiles témoigner d'un succès
retentissant qui n'a eu d'égal que son
imprévisibilité en effet en sciences on
peut dire les choses de façon précise ou
de façon simple mais rarement les deux à
la fois c'est la croix que cette image
plein de bonnes intentions de reporter
sans nous et aller trop longuement
dessus car en fait nous en avons déjà
parlé dans une précédente vidéo
pourquoi cette image ne rentrent pas
tout à fait justice à ce qu'elle est
censée illustrer comme un seul parent
pinalie un peu déjà le titre la marche
du progrès au marche vers le progrès non
vraiment la peine qu'on s'arrête là
dessus je pense que tout le monde a
compris ce qu'il ya de dérangeant là
dedans
deuxièmement l'accroissement de la
taille qui est en fait une donnée plus
ou moins indiscutable
passons maintenant à ce qu'il faut
vraiment souligner c'est à dire la
différence entre ce que veut nous dire
l'image est ce que nous comprenons voici
ce que l'image de nous dire l'homme est
proche parent du chimpanzé ainsi que de
tout un tas d espèces fossiles tels que
australopithèques us homo habilis ou
encore homo erectus avec qui ils
partagent des ancêtres communs
voici notre ancêtre commun avec
australopithecus avec homo habilis et
avec homo erectus les espèces fossiles
ne devrait pas une prendre cher car
elles sont disparus ce n'est toutefois
pas ce que nous comprenons de cette
image car elle mélange des ancêtres
communs
les fossiles et les espèces actuelles et
les met tous au même niveau et du coup
voilà ce que tout le monde comprend
c'est simpliste et finaliste et sa
perverti un peu le message d'origine
à n'en pas douter en même temps la façon
de présenter est telle qu'il est
difficile d'interpréter ce n'est
ce moment que l'homme a évolué d'un
trait mais demandez vous un instant
pourquoi c'est l'espèce humaine qui est
représentée là dessus est ce parce que
dans notre nombril perception du monde
c'est la flatterie notre ego
certainement mais ce n'est pas la
principale raison la vraie raison c'est
que port espèce humaine que nous sommes
nous sommes les seuls représentants
vivant de notre lignée tous nos cousins
homininés se sont éteints du coup c'est
vachement pratique pour raconter notre
histoire évolutive d'une seule traite de
la façon la plus simple possible bulle
regardez ça marche aussi avec le genre
est qu ce dernier représentant des
équidés par contre si vous prenez les
éléphants pour lesquels deux genres bien
distincts existe là en asie l'autre en
afrique
alors là ça vient petit peu plus
compliqué est en fait dès qu'un groupe
donnée présente un peu trop d'espèces
vivantes et fossiles vouloir en
représenter l'évolution de façon simple
et linéaire vous oblige à choisir votre
lignée de façon complètement arbitraire
et c'est très joli certes mais ce n'est
qu'une toute petite partie la vérité
mais alors si la valeur pédagogique de
cette image si médiocre et tous les
spécialistes vous le diront et de nous
apprendre que sur une infime partie de
la véritable histoire d'évolutif de
l'homme alors pourquoi pas un jupiter
cette image est elle aussi populaire
elle aurait dû disparaître de tous les
livres d'école depuis bien longtemps non
et bien c'est parce qu'elle est virale
son graphisme et son message simple et
accessible font d'elle une petite peste
qui se transmet avec une efficacité
remarquable
regardez je n'ai qu'à changer les hommes
préhistoriques en manchots pour
qu'immédiatement vous compreniez le
message l'homme descend du manche ou en
fait la viralité de cette image fait
d'elle un même est certainement l'un des
mêmes les plus redoutable elle est plus
viraux de ces derniers demi siècle
tiens mais en fait saviez-vous que les
mêmes et la mémétique sont à la base des
notions de biologie évolutive et oui
c'est en effet un biologiste de
l'évolution ricciardo king qui a inventé
et définit le mot même en 1976 dans son
livre le gène égoïste
il voulait alors expliquer comment les
jeunes se transmettre d'une génération à
l'autre mute et évoluent pour cela il
fait un parallèle avec la façon dont se
transmettent mute et évoluent les idées
en passant d'un serment un autre par le
biais du bouche à oreille de la culture
ou encore des médias est en fait plus
l'idée est inintéressante inutile à la
société
voire néfastes comme c'est le cas des
légendes urbaines par exemple ou des
superstitions plus le parallèle avec le
comportement égoïste des jeunes est bien
illustré une idée n'a pas forcément
besoin d'être bonne pour être virale de
même qu'un gel se transmet pour lui même
sans souci de conférer aux oignons un
avantage évolutif à l'organisme vivant
qui lui sert de véhicule
dawkins bâtisse ce type d'idées plus ou
moins contagieuses danon français et le
concept de même été les il est en fait
assez ironique de voir qu'un concept
inventé par un biologiste de l'évolution
à lui-même évolué pour devenir
aujourd'hui un élément marquant de la
culture populaire et que l'inde et même
les plus connus soit justement celui qui
représente l'évolution de façon
universelle
mieux encore c'est que là où tout
indiquait que la même éthique aurait dû
rester dans le cercle très fermé des
spécialistes de la biologie évolutive
elle a muté et évolué et s'est ensuite
immiscé dans la culture populaire
elle s'est répandue sur le net pour
devenir elle même finalement et très
ironiquement m
merci richard dawkins pour en savoir
plus sur le même de l'évolution et la
mémétique nous vous conseillons la
lecture du gène égoïste ainsi que du
pouce du pont d'oye du sourire du
flamant rose de stephen jay gould
merci à tous